i love this guy i love the chats he
dropped an incredible silence of the
lamb's reference
on an nfl network this past week
and um he's kyle brandt good morning
football and the host of 10 questions
with kyle brandt his podcast on spotify
and the ringer how are you brother
buffalo bill is hot right now rich as
are the buffalo bills well it's all
coming together you know again
um so let's just start with this chris
did you did you see
kyle brandt's silence of the lamb's
reference i did not
okay because now look um there's many
different ways one can go
with science the phrase i use all the
time is you covet what you see every day
right you could also go fava beans nice
chianti i mean there's many
many different ways you can go he
i'll give you the floor what did you
please please tell me oh yeah
because i remember okay i can't do it as
a justice as well as you so we were
doing
you know it was patriots versus raiders
and we were doing you know
we do a recurring segment where we
impersonate head coaches and i do with
john gruden and i do a belichick so
since they were playing
we did a whole segment of me doing
belichick and gruden
and the question was uh something about
who would have the better trick plays
and so
i come out and nate and peter debate and
then i come out and
i said you know i'm going to reference
the tuck rule because this is raiders
the only only uh the only trick play the
bell check no man
the only trick play i've seen is in that
sounds the lamb's flick they got this
this tatted up muchacho and he's dancing
and all of a sudden bam
changes things up on you man real fast
that's the only tuck rule i know man the
silence of the lambs man
and so we're just freaking out and going
off and then they tweeted out and
everybody's laughing and
it came out of nowhere i didn't even
know i was gonna do it it just came out
dude
i mean that was next i think i even
tweeted
the founding father of the network
there's certain things you can go to
there's a limit and there's a line and i
think in the sounds of the lamb's world
multiple migs uh the next cell down from
uh have a lecture would have been over
the line
but uh the basement of mr james gum aka
buffalo bill was as far as i could go
and when i'm in gruden mode anything
just comes out
i think you were encroachment uh in the
neutral zone
um on that reference i'm just wondering
there were no flags on the field right
there were no flags in the field
maybe a review for all i know maybe a
review and they went under the hood
but no flags and they'll find so i'm
good
okay kyle look man your coach of your
bears
yep has got some brass cojones i know
ten and a half quarters
and out despite a two-and-oh record
that i did not see coming that trubisky
would have i mean if you told me
that there would be a ten and a half
quarter leash i would i believe but at
two and oh
on the road um but it is foles's gig now
what are your
two cents on that one kyle yeah i think
he put it perfectly
matt nagy who as we know was coach of
the year not long ago
he's the guy at the table who he does
the kenny rogers he knows when to hold
him knows when to fold them let's not
forget
earlier in the season they were weighed
down way down to detroit
and already it's like we'll get follows
and trust he doesn't have he said nope
i'm gonna hold him i'm gonna hold and
sure enough trubisky launches this crazy
comeback and he wins
this time he just goes with his guts i'm
folding i'm walking away
and thereby ending i think the mitch
trubisky era in chicago it's an
unbelievable thing you know
matt maggie's deal is just it's bu
that's his brand that's your slogan it's
on his play card it's on his
office he just felt it he said i know i
stood with him last time and we had to
come back
but i'm going to go with my gut that's
why they pay me the big box
it is kind of a a closure and for for
chicago fans for bears fans
i was i was asked by a friend on a text
that how do you feel about moving on
from mitch
and do you feel any sense of loss and i
said listen
we've done everything we could to save
the relationship we went to therapy
we saw a counselor with mitch we had the
little puppets that you bring out and
you do the role playing with mitch to
try to express your feelings we tried
every single thing we could do yes and
we couldn't save the relationship
and now we moved on with this guy who's
got a super bowl ring and a statue and
it's pretty cool
well i'm hoping it works out kyle um
and that the foals that shows up is in
fact the foals that we saw
for the last um quarter and a half of
that game
um and the falls that uh philadelphia
enjoyed and potentially right now will
be missing for the rest of 2020.
um but that said if it was just
ten and a half quarters if that was the
leash
that the coach was going to give and
that
the ten and a half quarters is all that
you wanted to preserve
for trubisky to work out and that the
leash was in fact that short
then the whole concept of we can't bring
in somebody
who is so obviously going to supplant
mitch not just push not just be
competitive
when there's a competition that as we
all know covet prevented from happening
in the non-playing season
but if this was just ten and a half
quarters
i can't help but sit here and think what
cam would have looked like i know
the 2015 cam that's shown up in 2020 new
england if that guy was in chicago you
might be set for a decade
if not even for 2020 uh you know
the same way that new england is kyle
you know
cam question and the way you oppose a
rich is perfect and you've posted
this the whole season last few weeks
really it could be the story of the
season
and because if they go to the playoffs
that they knock around the bills and win
the east who knows
i mean we're conceivably talking now the
patriots could go to a super bowl
which is not just wouldn't be sports
history it'd be american history
it's it's as if phil jackson moved on
from jordan and kobe and just found some
guy who everybody gave up on
and went to the finals and won it it's
it's looked that good
it's been that impressive um and that's
listen the bears of course
yeah and maybe they did look at cam but
so did about 20 other teams i'm still
not even sure why he's not on the
panthers
but it is incredible it's the biggest
shock of the first three weeks of the
season
has been how good cam newton has looked
i know and uh and and the fact is is
that if the patriots do in fact go
to the super bowl or make a super bowl
run
uh every single team that had a shot at
cam
and let him sit at home until belichick
decided to get through his evaluation of
jared stidham
you know and the fact that we're sitting
here in the first
post tom brady season with brady
reunited with gronk
in tampa talking about the story of the
season being cam
um just shows you exactly how
wrong everybody else was and how they
should all
rue the day potentially or could one
want it ruining the day
2020. there is one team though that made
a major quarterback change
and is not ruined the day and that is
tampa itself
and let's not pretend that belichick is
is now just winning this battle and that
tampa bay is uh they're falling apart
it's not working no like they're
they're getting on track they're they're
getting sharper and gronk's getting
involved and they've gone through their
little preseason now
can we even imagine oh boy rich a
super bowl which is the new england
pages versus the tampa bay buccaneers in
tampa i mean
everybody's head would explode it'd be
the greatest storyline in nfl history it
would double the ratings of last night's
debate
i'll tell you that oh my gosh i mean by
the way
rich i'd ask you as as a broadcaster
and a host do you find yourself
empathizing with chris wallace or saying
get in the game wallace or hit the
buzzer or hit something
that was some theater last night i can't
imagine how tall his glass of whiskey
was after that well i guess
yeah you know i'll say this uh chris
wallace
uh last night um the position he was in
and the way that he was responding did
sound
like me taking away my children's ipad
you know it's what it sounded like at
times where where it would be like we
made an agreement
you agreed that when your time was up
with your
ipad you were going to give it back to
me without any sort of complaint
and then also hey look um you're going
to like what mom and dad haven't planned
for you if you give up your ipad right
now you're going to love this next thing
we have for you
give up your ipad literally that's what
happened
last night and just in my house
the children weren't listening i think
he was this close
to counting i'm going to count to three
presidents
we're a big counting house and that was
really the only trick
he had left in the bag i just uh and say
what you want about the guys on stage
there was amazing theater with wallace
and you're right he should have taken
the ipads away
and promise that you know you'll give
them back either the amazon kindle
or that your phone whatever it is and
maybe one of them stops talking but my
gosh
kyle brand here on the rich eisen show
it's a bye week for your pond
this week spotify mandated bye week
in which we uh remember when we used to
watch rich you'd watch uh
lost or sometimes even game of thrones
and out of nowhere
they would say oh no new episode this
week but we're gonna give an episode
that's gonna catch you up
if you haven't watched everyone in the
ass but
that is where we're at for 10 questions
on spotify
many more episodes to come this is the
bye week okay
so we will not release a new episode
however i have some work to do tonight
rich i'm interested in your thoughts on
this tomorrow on good morning football
it's a big
big interview that i'm doing solo we
are in business the nfl now with ac dc
who is releasing a new album and a new
song and it's 6 a.m eastern tomorrow i
have to interview brian johnson and
angus young
from ac dc one of them is in australia
one of them is in london yeah and i'll
be in my basement
okay and i got to ask him about you you
shook me all night long and all that
stuff where should i go with this thing
um i guess i don't know you could have a
poll question who's got the biggest
balls of them all in the nfl
yeah could do that that's right it's
buffalo bill
[Laughter]
well but that's got all sorts of delay
satellite delay
issues potentially written all over that
it does and it's
it's this here's his and here's the
pitfalls and you would totally get this
you got the satellite delay issues
you've got wildly different time zones
you've got
guys with crazy accents and you're
interviewing two of them so you have to
serve them up separately
if you just throw a question to the
group they don't know who's gonna go
it could be a fine mess but i'm hoping
we can just talk back in black and
thunderstruck and they'll go after but
i've never met the gentleman one of
them's in their 70s
and they're still rocking and rolling
they go
well listen if you've got issues with
two guys in their 70s and how to ask
questions and conduct an interview you
should call chris wallace not me
i'll call chris wallace i hope this
passed out hungover face down in the
gutter right now my
my heart goes out to you chris walsh
somebody has to get that guy a taser or
a blow dart or something
next time because we got a bunch of
debates to go ask kyle brennan our poll
question yeah
chris okay uh cal brandt today is the
anniversary of the debut of cheers
1982 i'm not sure if you're aware of
that okay sure
uh which show thrived the most after
replacing a main character
of course joey wong departed for kirsten
cheers mash
two and a half men nypd blue
okay uh i'm taking two and a half men
off i like ashton as much as the next
guy i didn't log a lot of time with mash
although i know i'm familiar with hot
licks houlihan
um nypd blue uh you're talking schroeder
and
uh it's the kid from save by the bell i
think
never mind these are all i'm going with
cheers
i celebrate kirsty ally i thought she
was fantastic in that show
she easily could have fallen on her face
and the show could have fallen apart i
thought she held her own
and as long as as clavin and norm are
sitting up at the
at the bar doing the heavy lifting that
show was gonna fly and i think it's
cheers
in a runaway the place where everybody
everybody
knows your name and i thought it's
cheers too because it wasn't just that
shelley long replaced it was coach
who passed away in the middle and you
know and then woody harrelson coming in
i mean my gosh
they did it twice there is a cup there
what show would you
there is a show that i would put on
there okay um and i'm wondering if you
have another show that
might have been missed right there the
one for me would be three's company
you know oh yeah sure suzanne summers no
no no no i'm talking about mr furley
mr furley i mean you got no norman felt
norman fell
out don knotts in i mean that's
significant
right that is that you know it's it's
nick foles replacing trubisky
immediately skyrocket the level of play
i think you're right
that mr roper out mr furley inn
is in fact the television sitcom
version of folds for trubisky i don't i
don't think you're far off right there
yes and everybody's eyes go to khalil
mack who i think would be the larry
of three's company who i think stole
every season with his wardrobe alone
that's true see brockman you're this is
beyond you right
did you never see three's company never
knock on my door
i mean i've heard of it i i know who's
on it i never watched suzanne summers
yeah i mean the opening credits alone
are just you know those credits back
then they would go on for like 26
minutes that's long
and they're on they're uh they're on a
merry-go-round and there's high jinks
and there's high chances
it's just as the kids would say a banger
we've been waiting for you
we've been waiting for you kyle uh so
who's not do you have next week already
in the shoot here or what for your party
we have
we have three that we're setting up for
the next several days
um in fact the one that we have
confirmed for next week something i'm
actually really looking forward to and a
person who's live an incredible life
mr donnie wahlberg hey who is a movie
star a tv star
still sells out arenas with the new kids
and is married to jenny mccarthy
and uh lost 45 pounds to be in the sixth
sense in the first scene and i have so
many questions about it
okay very good um and my kids would be
you know would love a um any mass singer
question that you could come up with
yeah yeah rich that's the thing too
right because i don't watch that
or but jenny is on the math singer oh
very much so
and i've seen gronk on there antonio
brown who is who's been the coolest one
when they take the mask off that you've
seen or the eyes and children
it has been um just nothing but uh my
thing that i really
have enjoyed is again my children are so
on the edge of their seat to see who's
unmasked
and they don't know any of them any of
them
literally there it's like my daughter
came in last week and told me that
somebody named rhymes
just got unmasked and i went literally
you know leanne
no i even went shonda i even went shonda
uh no and then the answer was busta
so and i just i just wanted to give her
a hug because she had
no idea who any of them were but it's
still delighted
it's still delighted okay and i know
that maybe i'll ask about busta rhymes
and i i actually i would have guessed
leanne too
wildly different person from boston not
related no doubt
uh kyle uh what do you got over there
chris well rich you have this thing with
your kids about if
one of the obamas shows up or lebron
james says you'll give them a hundred
dollars yes that's that is true because
they think uh it's the most famous
person in the world who's about to be
unmasked every time
and i have told them it is not going to
be and they said what will you give us
if it is lebron or beyonce it's any
obama
name and obama beyonce or lebron if it's
any of them the
each child gets a crisp 100 bill from
dad oh my gosh so even if it's it's
sasha or malibu
that's correct that is correct okay any
obama
any obama or i think you're safe or
beyonce or lebron
a crisp 100 bill and the other thing
that they get most
disappointed about i guess to bring this
full circle is the episode where there
is no unmasking but they catch everybody
up with highlights from previous
episodes
oh yeah i do not like that version of
the mass singer previously seen on the
masks
so which i would only ask has the mass
singer taken
the the the baton in your household away
from ultimate pass
i know that's hot for a while let's play
something it is
in fact filling the void of the
offseason of ultimate tag
yes but they got it they're very excited
they're very excited to see all three
they were very excited to see all
they've really never cared about texans
at steelers before in their entire life
but for them to see all three watt
brothers together
for the first time since the last
episode of ultimate tag delighted my
children yeah
can i can i share just very quickly
wrapping up something i learned about
derek watt
this week okay i asked the loud on good
morning football during the highlight
you know what you're always just
chatting during the highlight and trying
to make jokes i said if it's jj
and tj why doesn't derek go by dj i
asked him that too and his middle name
is john
right i know i asked the question and
steelers and chargers fans started
tweeting me and there's it's a
ridiculous reason but it's a really
funny one
um i'm not making this up he's on record
derek what is saying this that he's not
dj because growing up he watched a lot
of
full house and to him dj tanner
played by candace cameron that was the
dj so he's like that's the little
sister's name i don't want to be dj
that's the only reason
and that's his words how weird is that i
asked him the same question
in a in a three watt
zoom in advance of the first episode of
ultimate tag
and he said he just was a kid and just
wanted to be different from his brothers
so what's up with that i feel like i
feel like tommy lee jones
i need to see dr nichols here he lied to
me
what's up bring him in you switched the
samples
i falsified your research that devlin
mcgregor could bring you
pro exactly by the way just to bring
this
full full star this is the greatest
jewish goodbye with uh with god
we had jane lynch on yesterday and i
spent the first three minutes of my time
with her
about the fugitive and how bless you she
helped her
uh she she helped um richard kimball uh
what did you say
about the experience she said it was
amazing and that uh harrison ford did
not like the
script of their scene and he worked on
it with her
together that's so cool that's what he's
that's what she said
and then and then got freaked out at how
i was totally geeking out on the
fugitive with her yeah i think
one of my favorite excuses great chicago
movie all right you take care of
yourself kyle we'll see you on good
morning football
7 a.m uh next week back uh with uh 7 a.m
eastern uh and we'll see you back next
week on your pod with donnie wahlberg as
it drops every wednesday
thanks for the coy rich appreciate man
right back at you kyle brandt right here
on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here